Cela fait longtemps je n'ai pas fait un petit tour de magie dans une intro
(Attention Squeezie va nous époustoufler)
Voilà qui est mieux n'est-ce pas?
Clément ne me dis pas que tu as fait  exprès de pas faire le cut au bon moment au montage
pour que les gens découvrent les secrets de mes tours de magie
Les amis, aujourd'hui c'est une vidéo chelou mais j'ai trop envie de la faire parce que ce que j'ai découvert hier
c'est très bizarre
il y a une chaîne qui s'appelle "SYMPA" ok je sais pas si vous connaissez elle a quand même plus d'un million d'abonnés
et sur cette chaîne c'est que des vidéos extrêmement putaclic
qui propose des sortes de quiz comme par exemple découvre si tu peux passer le test d' agent spécial du fbi
Moi, Lucas Hauchard, ma carrière elle fait "couci-couça"
Couci-couça réutiliser ce terme s'il vous plaît en 2018 .
Alors j'aimerais bien assurer mes arrières et savoir si en cas de pénurie youtube
Je peux me reconvertir facilement et rejoindre les rangs du FBI.
Alors je vous propose qu'ensemble, on fasse quelques-uns de ces tests de la chaîne sympa c'est parti.
Ouhhh...
Attention top secret mais c'est quand même sur youtube et ça fait 2 millions de vues boooon
découvre si tu peux passer le test d' agent spécial du FBI
être agent spécial du FBI est l'un des emplois les plus difficiles à obtenir
selon les statistiques moins de 5% des candidats sont acceptés
Ah, un
mais moi ma communauté ont fait partie de ces 5 % gamin
répondre à un certain nombre de questions peut montrer si le candidat a
un potentiel naturel pour développer une pensée créative et des compétences de raisonnements logiques
ça se tient jusque-là ferais-tu partie des rares personnes à réussir le test ?
ok qu'est la première énigme je veux tout savoir !
2 pilules, un tueur en série kidnappait des gens et leur faisait prendre une sur deux pilules
l'une était inoffensive et l'autre était toxique.
quelle que soit la pilule prise par la victime
le tueur en série prenez l'autre. Chaque fois les victimes mouraient
et le tueur en série survivait
Comment le tueur avait t-il toujours la pilule inoffensive ?
Oh la la on a du temps!!
Euh...
y'avait...y a aucune pilule qui était...euh...y a aucune pilule qui était toxique c'était l'effet placebo
on va dire que c'est l'effet placebo inversée étant persuadé qu'il est tombé sur la mauvaise le mec meurt.
Pire théorie.
réponse :les deux pilules étaient inoffensives
FBI
le poison était dans le verre d'eau que les victimes buvaient
Recalé. Ouais bon après on a le droit de se tromper à une question tu vois, on peut comme même rejoindre le FBI
c'est pas...c'est pas foutu non plus quoi...
Boissons: un homme et une femme sont allés au restaurant pour dîner pendant qu'ils attendaient le plat principal elle a commandé cinq boissons avec des
glaçons qu'elle faisait très chaud et qu'elle était assoiffée. La femme en a vu quatre en même temps tandis que l'homme en a bu seulement une
après un moment l'homme est tombé malade et est mort. Les médecins ont affirmé que toutes les boissons étaient
empoisonnées pourquoi la femme est elle encore vivante quand l'homme était mort?
Laissez moi une minute
[musique]
Ok je sais! Cette femme a voulu tuer son mari pour toucher l'assurance vie elle est donc responsable du poison présent dans chaque verre et
dans l'intestin de son mari et a décidé de prendre un antidote avant de boire les boissons
regarder la réponse :le poison était dans les glaçons
C'est exactement ce que j'ai dit. Mais genre juste quelques lettres qui changent. Comme la femme a bu très rapidement les glaçons n'ont pas eu
le temps de fondre, l'homme quant à lui a vu très lentement et le poison a fondu dans sa boisson ouais ouais
c'est vrai c'est une explication parmi les autres mais si je puis me permettre
on dirait pas les énigmes que tu racontes en colo c'est quand il est bien tard et quand tu fais chier vraiment un groupe de potes
magnétophone
imagine la scène suivante
un homme a été retrouvé mort avec un pistolet dans sa main et un
magnétophone à côté de lui
le détective appuyer sur le bouton play et à écouter le message le message disait je suis fatigué de cette vie et j'ai décidé de
dire adieu à ma douleur et la souffrance suivi d'un son de coups de feu le détective ne croit pas à l'hypothèse du suicide
pourquoi la détective pense-t-il que c'était un meurtre
Ah ok j'ai la solution ce que vous voyez à côté du corps ce n'est pas du tout un magnétophone c'est un poste de radio
à l'ancienne quand l'enquêteur est arrivé sur les lieux du crime et il se trouve que cette radio envoyez de la musique celle des black
eyed peas qui s'appelle l'aide des leafs are said les dialyses certaines qui veut dire laissons le commencer les sur le comment c'est quoi
l'enquète de qui parle-t-il de l'enquêteur tout cela n'est qu'un jeu l'homme allongé n'est pas mort il s'agit d'un mannequin salle enquêteurs n'en sait rien
puisqu'il a pas médecin légiste tout cela avec une vulgaire mise en scène de la part de quelqu'un qui soit de jouer avec la police
sans tuer personne c'est bon réponse si l'homme s'est suicidé comment aurait-il pu rembobinez la cassette jusqu'au début
La réponse est oui ouais mec nous on est trop jeune pour ça moi le magnétophone j'ai cru que c'était un lecteur de cd
m'annoncer c'est un lecteur de cd il aurait dit lecteur de cd je cherche des excuses
voilà c'est bon bravo à tous ce qu est la bonne réponse encore une fois
pour être honnête pour sûr ça j'ai pas trop réfléchi pas fait d'effort allez on y va
mystère de noël un détective mettait en garde pendant les vacances de noël et le matin du 25 décembre il a reçu un appel et
s'est rendu chez quelqu'un il a sonné à la porte et une minute plus tard un propriétaire de maison ou encore à moitié endormi a
ouvert cette dernière le détective a dit votre voisin indiqué hier lors du réveillon de noël
il est venu chez vous pour faire la fête et pendant qu'ils étaient là vous êtes rentré dans sa maison et vous avez volé des
objets de valeur battu un cépage en tue soit je vous prêtez a répondu ce n'est pas vrai notre famille a célébré le réveillon de
noël chez des amis nous avons à peine eu le temps de décorer notre arbre de noël
le détective a déclaré pas d'inquiétude il est assez évident pour moi que votre voisin est un menteur comment le détective savait-il
Bon cette fois j'ai la solution d'impôt devrait j'ai vraiment réfléchi
si le réveillon du voisin de cet homme c'était bel et bien passé chez cet homme
on est d'accord qui aurait eu du monde u rue beaucoup de déchet beaucoup de débris en tous cas chez cet homme le mec vient
tout juste de se lever l'un du matin il est déphasée les dégâts alors à quel moment exactement
aurait-il eu le temps de ranger tous les débris de la fête
à aucun moment il est donc évident que le voisin mans et que le réveillon n'a jamais eu lieu chez cet homme là la chaussure
j'ai bon les guirlandes lumineuses de l'arbre de noël sont débranchés et le manque d'ailleurs une ampoule elle ne fonctionnerait pas sans l 1 il
était clair pour détective que propriétaire c'est la vérité il avait décoré le sapin avec tellement précipitations qui n'avait même pas vérifié s'il ya un
an 2009 fonctionner ou non
C'est complètement la merde mais beck haas encore plus simple de prouver le truc avec ma théorie un mois il est crevé vient de se
lever le gars est genre chez lui tout est nickel
ranger en bref c'est chiant explique jean paul giroud s'est mieux tenu que la guerre entre
bravo à ceux qui ont eu raison et je pense qu'ils sont 0 qui est la mère la mère teresa regarde l'image ouais
je regarde berlin il ya deux ans dans une pièce qui sont assises l'une en face de l'autre tandis qu'un petit garçon joue par terre
qui selon toi est la vraie mère de l'enfant
celle de gauche parce que l'enfant il en train de jouer vers la meuf de gauche voilà c'est l'explication das réponse
la mère de l'enfant et la dame à gauche elle est assise avec ses jambes diriger vers l'enfant
c'est exactement ce que j'ai dit mais dans l'autre sens l'enfant diriger vers la maman hutin
je partis que le fbi haribo la posture de la femme à gauche et protectrice légèrement incliné vers l'avant il est naturel pour les petits
enfants de faire face à leur mère si elle est là lorsqu'ils jouent ou font une activité
c'est exactement ce que j'ai dit oh non c'est fini je suis dégoûté alors je peux dire un truc je sais ma vidéo donc oui
façon déjà dans ce dernier truc c'est vraiment de l'analyse du comportement et ses ex vraiment dans la vraie vie vraiment vous pouvez savoir un
petit peu les uns les intentions des gens juste en analysant leurs comportements leurs postures leur manière de bouger leur gestuelle parce qu'inconsciemment
on envoie des tas de messages avec notre corps involontairement
voilà ça intéresse très peu de gens
Ooooohhh ouuuii
Y'a six jours le deuxième test pour le FBI
Un serial killer. Ouais c'est en anglais parce qu'au FBI on parle en anglais du coup il teste notre anglais
Un serial killer a invité une future victime chez elle
ils ont mangé ensemble après quoi elle lui a offert une pomme. La victime ayant dit qu'elle n'avait plus faim, le tueur à coupé
la pomme en deux pour qu'il la partage
ok ils ont tous les deux commencé à manger leurs morceaux de pommes mais aussitôt l'inviter à manger la pomme
aussitôt elle est décédée. Pourquoi l'un des deux est mort et l'autre a survécu?
ok elles avaient éclaté les pépins en petits morceaux... non c'est de la merde ma théorie. Oh ça y est je sais...
elle a empoisonné un seul côté de la lame du couteau
du coup en coupant la pomme ça a juste empoisonné un
côté de la pomme. Au mec, j'suis sûr c'est ça! oh c'est sûr j'ai la bonne réponse
Le tueur a utilisé un couteau qu'elle a empoisonné seulement d'un côté de la lame
Je vous jure je suis trop content c'est incroyable. Ok deuxièmement un mystère chimique, vous avez vu là je m'échauffe , oh je rigole plus je suis dans la
cour des grands, j'suis dans la cour des enquêteurs. Oh putain un chimiste célèbre a été retrouvé mort dans son laboratoire.
La police savait que deux personnes étaient impliquées dans le meurtre
et il y avait cinq suspects Felix Joshua Nicolas, Nathan et Peter. La police a trouvé note écrit par le chimiste:
26-3-58/28-27-57-16. Bah ça c'est des trucs du tableau des éléments, faut juste regarder.
Non mais tu as le droit de faire ça pendant le test du FBI. Vous en faites pas regarder. Alors 26/3/58: Fe/li/ce
28/27/57/16: Ni/Co/La.
Voilà, donc c'est Felice et Nicolas. Mais mec, on dirait un exercice de physique chimie de troisième. C'est
scandaleux
C'est pas du tout pour aller au FBI mec. Ok troisième énigme, c'est pas grave. Meurtre chez soi. Un homme a été retrouvé mort un dimanche après-midi.
Au moment où le meurtre a été commis, il y avait quatre personnes dans la maison. Quatre suspects  potentiels
Jackson. La femme,
le cuisinier, la bonne et le jardinier.
Chacun a dit à la police ce qu'il était en train de faire au moment du meurtre. La femme a dit
j'étais en train de lire un livre. Le cuisiner a dit
j'étais en train de cuisiner un breakfast. Mais est-ce que quand il est mort c'était pas après le breakfast?  alors t'étais en train de cuisiner un breakfast à
une heure qui ne correspond pas au moment où on mange le breakfast? Tu me prend pour un con! J't'aime pas toi! La bonne a
dit: j'étais en train de mettre la table, et le jardinier a dit j'étais en train d'arroser les plantes. Qui est le
meurtrier et comment la police a su? alors déjà vous travaillez tous beaucoup trop bien
ce n'est pas possible. Y'a forcément l'un de vous qui a mytho et qui était en train de faire autre chose que ce qu'il
devait faire
parce que c'est un voyou. Vous savez quoi, franchement je la joue dans les temps et tout c'est le cuisinier. Je le sens pas, non mais tu cuisines
pas, il était trop tard pour cuisiner c'est sûr.
Tu vois pourquoi enquêter quand à l'instinct ça passe. Le cuisinier l'a fait. Tu ne cuisine pas le déjeuner dans
l'après-midi. Bah oui tu le cuisines avant. Mais ils auraient dû mettre dans le titre pour les moins de 7 ans la sur celui-là. Argent volé.
Oui j'écoute bien sûr.
Encore les mêmes! c'est le cuisiner.
c'est le cuisinier c'est sûr c'est toujours lui! Un homme a mis un billet de 100 dollars sur une table puis est allé travailler. Quand
il est revenu la monnaie avait disparu. Il a trois suspects: le cuisiner, la bonne et
l'électricien. Le cuisiner a dit: "j'ai mis le billet sous un livre, pour le mettre en sécurité"
La bonne a dit: "j'ai mis le billet dans le livre entre la page 10 et 11, pour le mettre en sécurité".
non mais attends
non mais déjà, il a tous ces gens là chez lui. Le billet, tu peux le mettre sur la commande en évidence ils sont pas
censés te le voler. Donc ils sont pas censés te le mettre en sécurité
ton putain de billet! Il y a un gros problème de confiance là entre ces gens, on est d'accord? On reprend
l'homme a checké dans le livre et il  y avait rien entre la page 10 et 11. L'électricien a dit: "j'ai vu le billet
sortir un peu du livre et je l'ai bougé entre la page 11 et 12 pour le maintenir en sécurité. Il ya un gros problème
dans cette maison. Bon on récapitule, le cuisiner il a pris le billet, il l'a mis sous le livre, la bonne
elle a vu le billet alors qu'il est sous le...
comment est-ce qu'elle a vu le billet, alors qu'il était sous le livre? la bonne est coupable
Voilà bah moi je le fais au flair vous allez voir regardez, je me trompe jamais en plus. Regardez bien vous allez voir.
Bon un électricien une bonne, franchement ça se ressemble un peu déjà, déjà non pour ma défense ah oui je suis débile
En gros, ouais, je vous explique, ouais ça c'est la signature d'Alain Rey, ouais, non mais voilà bon. Page 10, page 11, le billet. Page 11,
page 12: comment tu caches entre ces deux pases?
J'arrive plus à articuler aujourd'hui. Ok, putain c'est la dernière énigme de la vidéo
le FBI m'a dit que si on passé celle ci, on peut rejoindre ses rangs. Alors on se concentre
sss'il vous plaît. Du froid sur les fenêtres.
C'est le nom. Ben a été retrouvé mort dans son étude par son ami John. John a alors appelé la police et leur a dit
ce qu'il s'était passé. Il a dit: "j'ai vu une lumière qui venait de sa chambre.
J'ai décidé d'aller voir de dehors s'il était là et il y avait du givre sur la fenêtre. Alors je l'ai essuyé et c'est là que
j'ai vu le corps. J'ai alors enfoncé la porte de la pièce pour vérifier ce que j'avais vu et je suis tombé sur le corps
de mon ami. J'ai immédiatement appelé la police."
L'officier a immédiatement su que john mentait.
Comment il a su?
J'ai la réponse! L'ami est
coupable car plutôt que d'appeler la police au moment où il a vu le corps de son ami étendu sur le sol, il a préféré
entrer: ce qui est totalement illogique
Il aurait dû appeler la police avant. Nous allons peut-être rejoindre le FBI.
Le givre d'une fenêtre se forme du côté qui est à l'intérieur de la pièce et non pas à l'extérieur.
John n'aurait donc pas pu essuyer le givre pour voir son ami.
Les amis c'est la fin du test
J'espère que vous l'avez passé avec succès: ce n'est pas mon cas! J'ai un peu le seum. Oui c'est vrai! bon bravo à cette chaîne youtube qui a
juste pris les énigmes qui sont connues depuis huit ans mais qui a eu l'ingéniosité de marquer test pour rejoindre le FBI.
Ca fait longtemps qu'on n'a pas fait des petits quizz, qu'on n'avait pas fait travailler les méninges. Ca a quand même fait kiffer même si c'est
de la bonne grosse connerie. Gros bisous à très vite!
Oh C'est ce que tu marques dans la fin d'un sms que tu envois à ta maman ça. Vrai ou Faux?
Énorme , hé  like si tu t'es reconnus
Enorme
J"me fatigue
Sow